my son couldn't afford the life-saving
medication he needed he had insurance
through his job even so his prescription
cost him $1,200 a month more than his
rent so last year he switched to a
cheaper over-the-counter version the
switch caused a shock to his system
within months he died I prioritized the
heart stuff over the insulin because the
heart stuff is more immediate I know
over time diabetes will kill me but
it'll take a longer time and I know that
without the heart failure drugs I only
have 133% function of my heart I don't
want to play with that okay I don't like
the stress of thinking about how I'm
going to pay for my meds you know how's
it going to cuz I'm never going to have
any more money or any less money a new
study finds one in three Americans on
Medicare and who do not qualify for
lowincome subsidies do do not fill
prescriptions for their Cancer drugs
because of the sworn cost as many as
230,000 of our veterans are suffering
from hepatitis C but fortunately there
is a cure for it and the VA cannot
provide it because it's too expensive if
your child needed a medication that cost
$2.1 million how would you pay for it
medication zenma which is used to treat
spinal muscular atrophy which can be a
fatal condition currently costs $2.1
million I have stage 4 lung cancer and I
am on an immunotherapy medication that
is quite literally keeping me alive and
for the 2 and 1/2 years that I've had
cancer this whole time that I've been on
this medication I thought that it was
$2,500 a month my medication does not
cost $2,500 a month it cost
$21,000 a month but like
$21,000 for one
bottle everyone knows that prescription
drugs in America are insanely expensive
just take your average asthma inhaler
for example without insurance an inhaler
in America cost around $400 in France
that same inhaler goes for just 50 bucks
and the French inhaler isn't some cheap
lowquality alternative it's literally
the exact same one as in the US this
means that somewhere between the inhaler
being produced and it being sold to some
American sucker someone is pocketing
that $350 difference and that someone
could be you there are billions to be
made by ripping off Americans in big
Pharma but if you want in on some of
those billions you got to know who's
pocketing the most money
but figuring out exactly where all that
money is going isn't exactly easy big
farmer is very secretive and for good
reason no big farmer executive wants
poor Grandma su's social security check
being traced back to their pockets so
the details of this industry are kept a
careful secret but that doesn't mean a
few things haven't slipped out over the
years over the years many people have
started to point the finger at Pharmacy
benefit managers or pbms pbms are
middlemen and reports have been swolling
for years about how these evil middlemen
make billions by jacking up prescription
drug prices even the people in the
industry love pointing the finger at
pbms but is that really all there is to
it big farmer is huge so are these
middlemen really the only ones
responsible for Crazy Prices like these
or are PBM just a convenient scapegoat
for everyone to put the blame on well to
find out I decided to ask an Insider say
hi to Doug Barons Doug was high up in
the big farmer industry for about 30
years so he understands exactly how the
industry works and where all those juicy
profits actually goes 72% of Americans
take at least one medication and 35% of
Americans take at least three
medications a day so we consume 80% of
all the prescriptions in the world and
as sadly as that what you alluded to is
that we have a prescription drug cost
problem in America let's just say in my
30 years in the industry prescription
drugs used to be 2 cents of the
healthcare dollar and now it's 30 to 50
cents of the healthcare dollar it's on
what they say it's driving the
healthcare dollar after he got disgusted
with the insane greed in big Pharma he
left it all behind to create America
First Pharmacy where all you have to do
is pay an affordable monthly membership
and you'll get access to 800 plus
generic medications for free so Doug has
some pretty eye openening things to say
about how big Pharma actually works so
sit back relax and let's learn how to
get
[Music]
rich our journey starts with the drug
manufacturers as a drug manufa the name
of the game is inventing new drugs and
getting a patent for it now you may be
thinking but Jake inventing new drugs
are actually better than the current
drugs is really really hard and yes it
is but luckily there is no law in
America saying that new drugs have to be
better than existing drugs they just
have to be new people like shining new
things more on this later but yeah
penting new drugs is the name of the
game a pent gives you 20 years of
complete control over your new drug from
the moment it was invented that's more
than enough time to get it tested
approved so you can sell it for whatever
ever price you want and that is the
beauty of America see in other countries
you can't just sell drugs for whatever
price you want go to any other country
in the world and the process of setting
drug prices looks very similar a drug
manufacturer invents a new drug they
patent it test it get it approved and
then it goes to the government where
Regulators decide whether the country
really needs this new drug and what the
fair price for it should be in Australia
the committee in charge of approving new
drugs is so strict that it's actually
denied half of the anti-cancer drugs
that have applied over the past 10 years
all because of the benefits of these new
drugs didn't seem to be worth the cost
even if big farmer companies in other
countries wanted to overcharge they're
not allowed to but lucky for you none of
this applies in America you won't find
the American government doing something
as socialist as price controls they're
not going to ensure citizens can afford
the medications they need no no no in
America we live by the free market
economy and if you can't afford it well
you can die by it too which brings us to
step number
two
[Music]
in America s there is no such regulatory
committee to decide if new drugs are
actually worth it you do not need to
prove that your drug is better than the
ones already on the markets as long as
you can show your product is safe and
effective the FDA will approve it and
then you can sell it for as much as you
want so if you decide to charge $11,000
for a pill that only cost you $1 to make
well no one is forcing Louis Vuitton or
Chanel to lower their prices if someone
can't afford it they should probably
budget better they should probably work
harder just look at what the former CEO
of Bayer one of the biggest
pharmaceutical companies in the world
said when he was asked about how India
is trying to create a cheaper version of
a cancer drug bearer was selling that
Bearer charges almost $70,000 a year for
this is what he said qu is it going to
have a big effect on our business model
no because we did not develop this drug
for the Indian market let's be honest we
developed this product for Western
patients who can afford this product End
quotes they literally invented the drug
just so they can charge prices only
westerners can afford but it gets even
better because once your drug is
approved by the FDA you're practically
guaranteed sales see in other countries
people would just avoid buying drugs
that are insanely expensive if there was
a cheaper alternative available but in
America we've got a little something
called Medicaid and Medicaid has given
its members coverage for all FDA
approved drugs no matter how much they
cost so if a doctor prescribes a $1,000
drug to a Medicaid patient even if
there's a cheaper $100 alternative
Medicaid has to pay for it and all those
sweet American tax dollars go straight
into your pockets this part is not very
free market of America at all but it
does work in your favor you don't need
to worry about improving drugs you just
need to make sure whatever drugs do get
approved are as expensive as possible
but once you do have a new drug patented
how are you going to get the ward out
well that brings us to step number three
whipping out the marketing
[Music]
machine
side effects like nausea vomiting and
diarrhea may lead to dehydration which
may worsen kidney problems looking to
get back in your type two diabetes Zone
ask your healthcare provider today about
once weekly OIC you may pay as little as
$25 for a 3-month prescription thanks to
Sky rzy there's nothing like clearer
skin and better
movement and that means
everything Now's the Time to ask your
doctor about sky rzy learn ABY could
help you save America is the only
country in the world where drugs are
advertised on TV just like Pepsi during
the Super Bowl the only other country
that allows us is New Zealand which is
pretty crazy to think about it's
mindboggling mindboggling and the the
such the disconnect is the fact that we
allow manufacturers to advertise drugs
on TV but yet an American can't go right
to their computer and buy a drug so why
are you advertising it's like
advertising a pizza on TV while you're
watching a football game but you can't
go buy it it's it's it's bizarre so they
advertise I I guess hoping hoping that
when you go see your doctor you're going
to bring up the name I mean Sky Rizzy
for goodness sakes what does Sky Rizzy
have to do with watching Monday Night
Football Sky Rizzy is a very new drug
but it's the regiment is $177,000 a
month you tell me what American can sit
there on the couch and go oh yeah I want
Sky RZ I think I'll order that $117,000
a month it's I I don't know that's it's
I I find the disconnect why they would
do that pharmaceutical companies spend
over $6 billion a year marketing their
drugs to the masses and they keep doing
it because it works they're going to go
to their doctor and say hey I saw Sky
Rizzy is that something for me or or or
you know OIC is obviously another
another one in other countries there may
only be one or two drugs available to
treat a specific condition so someone
goes to the doctor and the doctor will
only have one or two drugs available to
prescribe to them but in America the
more the merrier there are so many
different types of drugs on the market
that doctors have a lot of different
choices to choose from it's kind of like
the secret menu at Starbucks patients
can actually ask for a specific drug
they saw on TV and although the doctor
is not supposed to listen to them
depending on how open-minded the doctor
is they might consider it that is the
beauty of big Pharma in America why
spend decades perfecting a safer more
effective drug when you can just make a
more marketable drug and then blast Amer
with ads about it but keep in mind all
this marketing will be useless if
doctors don't know about your drug the
patient will ask about your drug that
the doctor never heard of and it will
just go in one ear and write out the
other so you got to BRB I mean mark it
to the doctor's
[Music]
next people respond to incentives when
there's money companies respond doctors
respond everybody so an OP olist called
me a few weeks ago there's a drug and
and the drug works okay it's good it's
good for people if you if something
called wet macular degeneration okay
it's something older people get and it
can blind you so there's a drug there's
a couple drugs that actually work for it
they Opthomologist administer them in
their offices so a drug like that the
opthalmologist actually buys and charges
Medicare or the private insurer for okay
what's happening and I saw this with a
different drug when I worked in the New
York Times 15 years ago so nothing ever
changes these companies all play the
same games is that the companies that
make this drug are giving doctors a
rebate on the purchase price and the
more you use the bigger the rebate and
this is a drug that costs thousands of
dollars per person per year okay it's
dose multiple times a year for a lot of
these people so what all this adds up to
is if you're an opthalmologist who's
using a lot of this the company is
cutting you in check for five or
sometimes six figures sometimes multiple
times a year okay don't tell me that
that's not a bribe okay cuz that's a
bribe it may be legal they may have
found a way to do this and he showed me
he showed me the check that his company
or that his Opthalmology practice had
received and it was huge okay and by the
way these doctors make a lot of money on
their own just doing the procedure they
don't need this but it's a way for the
drug company to get them to use this
more and so in this case the guy
actually said to me he's like this is a
good drug it does work he said but
sometimes if we dose it too many times
we can get there can be sort of a
paradoxical effect where it stops
working if you're one of those doctors
who's on the tit and getting that check
every quarter every 6 months or you know
however frequently you get it it's going
to be harder for you to see the problem
because all of the sudden you have a
financial incentive not to see it
according to Pro publica more than 2,500
doctors were paid at least half a
million dollar each in the space of just
5 Years From drug makers and biotech
companies they've also proven that
doctors who get these incentives from
Big Pharma are always more likely to
prescribe their drugs to patients it's
the classic reciprocity bias when
someone does something nice for you like
hand you half a million dollars you're
more likely to do something nice to them
back like prescribe their drugs in every
other Industries prices tend to go down
over time as manufacturing improves and
whatnot but not big Pharma for some
reason prices are only going up nearly
half of all Americans say their
prescription drug prices have gone up
over the last year big farmer will say
this is because we got a fun New
research and development everybody in
America we live in a capitalist
economy and you know greed profit is not
a problem greed is where we uh we have
some issues there are 18 million
Americans who can't afford their
life-saving prescription medication and
we are going to keep it that way now you
may be saying but Jake this is great and
all but what happens when the patent on
your drug expires is there just no more
money to be made no see when a patent
expires any other drug maker can produce
your drug as long as they make an exact
onetoone copy of your formula and yes
these generic versions of your drugs
will only cost them a few cents to make
but does that mean the drug is going to
get cheaper for patients no see what
most people don't know is that most of
the prescription drugs people take in
America are generic there's no patent on
these drugs and yet the masses still
have to pay an arm and a leg for them
when they only cost a few cents to make
why well it's because of all the other
players in the industry with the next
one being the
[Music]
pbms pbms are are probably the most
hated people in the pharmaceutical
industry and for good reason they are
the middlemen take a really big company
with a lot of employees for example if
you have over a 100 employees in America
like Ford or whatever you got to provide
health insurance to your employees and
part of that health insurance has to
cover prescription drugs and how are you
going to handle this prescription drug
portion well you have to go to a PBM
what a PBM is prescription benefit
management company they manage the
prescription benefit program for
self-insured employers and I don't know
what the number is but anybody any
employer over a 100 employees usually
it's more beneficial to be self-employed
you know they have to go out and hire a
PBM to manage the drug portion of it
you've got somebody managing the vision
the dental the major Med and they happen
to do the prescription drugs and like I
alluded to when I got in this industry
is two cents of the healthcare dollar
that's 30 to 50 cents many would say
that they probably have through their
tricks and uh games or whatever I should
be saying I'm trying to be gentle here
Jake that that they're probably the
number one cause of of the increase of
the inflation of the drug cost now it's
a$ 645 billion industry and when the
three top pbms come out every in the
first quarter I I remember this from
this year and they pounded their chest
CU they were proud that they made $61
billion a piece in one quarter that's
three months that's a lot of money
that's a lot of profit and some people
in the industry they scratch their head
and go you're supposed to be in the
middle managing my drug cost and saving
me money when all they've been doing is
sticking their hand in the cookie jar
but that's just one way PBM skim off the
masses there are many other ways pbms
push up the price of drugs if you come
into my Pharmacy if your grandma comes
in and she tries to fill a prescription
I'll give you metformin my cost on met
foran is roughly $2 I would sell her
metformin for $4 as soon as she
discloses that she has insurance I have
a gag clause I not allowed to tell her
my cash pay price I swipe her insurance
card Blue Cross whatever it may be boom
copay $10 and she gets her medicine I
charge her $10 immediately when I swipe
that card and I enter all that in the
computer I get a $7 callback where does
it go it goes to the vbm and everything
they do they keep it a secret well so
Pharmacy benefit managers though they
they say that they're negotiating prices
where can I go to learn how much they're
saving leing us I haven't seen anything
publicly available that reports that me
neither Pharmacy benefit managers don't
reveal to either health insurance
companies or patients or pharmacies
exactly who's getting what deal and they
make money at every step of the process
they pocket money from drug
manufacturers they pocket money from
pharmacies they pocket money from health
insurance plans and nobody knows if
they're actually driving down the cost
but like what we said earlier tbms are
the easy ones to blame drug
manufacturers are the easy ones to blame
what everyone forgets about when it
comes to why drugs are so expensive in
America are the retail pharmacies you
all know their names CVS Walgreens
Target Walmart when most people think of
big Pharma and like all all the negative
connotations of it they typically think
of the manufacturers but earlier you
said the actual pharmacies play a big
role in in price gouging if I answer
this question Jake I'm not going to get
too many Christmas cards from the retail
pharmacies in America yeah you're right
the the story I alluded to is that I I
think if you were to pull nine out of 10
of Americans I think they would probably
Point their finger at the drug
manufacturers because that's what
they've been led to believe maybe some
of the politicians over the decades have
uh pointed that way but really the true
answer is the retail pharmacies that's
where they get the drug like we've
mentioned several times already they get
them for 2 three cents a pill and
they're charging outrageous prices for
them so the manufacturers they actually
for the generic drugs at least they
actually sell for like 2 cents to the
middlemen and thees yeah it's it's that
low it's a the to to your point the same
pill that is sold at all those retail
pharmacies Walgreens Walmart CVS Riot a
and all the others the grocery store
chains whatever the wholesalers that
sell those drugs those medications to
those Outlets are the same ones that we
buy Ours from so we actually have the
same pill the same medication if you
were to switch a drug from a retail
pharmacy SE us it would look exactly the
same cuz it's the exact same pill so
what is the solution to all of this well
that is why Doug created America First
Pharmacy this pharmacy program you get
you pay your monthly membership fee get
access to the top 90% of the most
utilized drugs in America those nine out
of 10 drugs are the drugs if they were
walking out of a pharmacy today the
consumer our fellow American would pay
zero for those that top 90% I'm account
for about 815 medications 27 of those
are acutes acute medications are
immediate Need You Know M or D take
Johnny or Susie to the doctor they have
the sniffles you need a MOX cylinder
zpack immediately so you go to Every
Pharmacy United States put our
membership card down and you're going to
walk out paying zero for those remaining
688 medications on the program are come
out of our facility here in atan Ohio
mailed to your home in 1 to two days
with free shipping and traceable
trackable by the US Postal Service
America First Pharmacy works like a gym
membership where you pay an affordable
monthly membership fee and you get
unlimited access to 90% of the most used
prescription drugs in America of course
you still need a prescription and it's
already saving Americans a ton of money
we had a gentleman he called into the
office here and he had ended up being on
five medications and he had just made a
purchase before he became a member
before he heard about us he was just
kind of came across the program was
inquisitive called our customer care
team and was just hey what's this drug
cost and they're trained to ask do you
have any more and he had he had five
like I said well he just went to a
retail pharmacy I'm not going to say the
name but it's very popular and he paid
$2,800 for those five medications you
know what he paid on our program for
those five medications zero he paid his
monthly membership fee because he became
a member he now gets those five
medications for free where he paid
$2,800 just quick math that's over
$10,000 a year if I recall that's a
tremendous savings um we just had a
gentleman the other day just a case in
point it's a fresh one so he was was on
$400 he was spending $400 a month on his
medications and now he came across our
program and is now paying zero and
that's why they wanted to sponsor this
video to help get the word out that if
you're being screwed over with high drug
prices it does not have to be this way
all you have to do is scroll down click
the link below and check out their
website now America First Pharmacy is
perfect for you if you don't have
insurance or if you're functionally
uninsured where the deductible you have
to pay is so high that you just can't
afford it so if you or anyone you know
is in this situation scroll down click
the link below and share it with them
now getting rid of these insane
Financial incentives is the first step
in corralling in this insane big farmer
industry in America so I'm really happy
to support them so if you need to click
the link below to sign up for America
First pharmacy
[Music]
now oh